I did two baking soda wraps that I watched on Barbaroneel's YouTube and now I am feeling
depleted. I don't feel good now. Is this normal? Ah, I don't know. I have not ever done
a baking soda wrap and I'm really not even familiar with a baking soda wrap that this person
advocates. So baking soda is sodium bicarbonate and it's a strong base. Now the whole idea
acid base balance, you know if any of you have been with me long enough have heard my
take on that and that cancer can grow in an alkaline environment that you need to alkalize
your body and cancer is only grows in an acidic environment. To me that is just a bunch
of hui. So I think any highly metabolic cell is going to produce a lot of waste and that
waste is going to be acidic. It's not because it's not growing because it's an acidic
environment. It's created an acidic environment. Now I know Dr. Stephen Gini inject baking soda
at the site of the cancer and had some success. How much success he had? We don't know.
He ended up throwing in jail in Italy for what he did. We have no idea. Maybe he got thrown
in jail because he was helping people. Maybe he got thrown in jail because he hurt people.
We just don't know. I do think that if you injected baking soda at the site of a cancer
to me it makes sense that it would actually help from physiological standpoint because at
the site of the cancer is very acidic. However, to get baking soda or to get an alkaline solution
at the site of a cancer you'd have to inject it. If you're going to ingest it, take it
it orally and you don't have cancer in the stomach or the first part of the small intestine.
It's just going to break down and you're not you're just making your stomach alkaline. That's
like taking alcohol and water to me. It makes no physiological sense whatsoever because you're
just alkalizing your stomach acid which you're just completely counterintuitive to how your
body has to use hydrochloric acid to digest. Plus you have what's called a buffering system in
your body that will buffer anything. But if you expose yourself to too much acid you can make
yourself ill for a period of time. You expose yourself to too much base or alkaline product you
can make yourself ill. So don't just think because it's alkaline, it's good. High degree of alkalinity
is just as caustic as a low pH of low acidic solution is caustic. You want to burn somebody. You
know, you spill some sulfuric acid on them. You want to burn somebody with some high you know a
concentration of a high pH product that you can still burn somebody. It's just as caustic and
this is dangerous. So the idea you're going to measure pH on a person is really ridiculous. You
can't measure urinary or salivary pH and say this person is alkaline or acidic. All it says is
there a urine is alkaline acidic and if you give a person some minerals they'll probably alkalize
their urine because they'll spill extra minerals in their urine which is how your body buffers the
acid-based system. So I don't know, I just drink a lot of water personally. Try to flush anything out
of your body and just get your body back and balance that way. That's what I would do with anything.
Remember, that's one of the best ways to help your body in any hyper-exposure of anything,
whether it's a hyper-exposure of pollen or a hyper-exposure of, you know, bad food, you know,
drink a lot of water. The old saying that dilution is the solution to pollution is
is a cute little saying and it's so true. Your body, if you dilute it, you're going to help
decrease the pollution and help flush out that thing of your body, whatever that is.